(audience cheering)
How would you folks like to see me
and Andy having an Epic Saber Battle?
(audience cheering)
[Narrator] Totally
edible, Conan and Andy's
Epic Saber Battel.
Come on Andy, come on.
(crowd laughing)
Andy come on.
Andy what are you doing?
Come on, wait a minute Andy.
I've got no verve Conan no pep.
Andy what's wrong?
You got you look terrible out here.
You're sluggish.
I don't have any energy.
Alright I know what's gonna
to help you out old pal
and that's one thing right here.
That's right a Snickers bar.
A snickers bar?
Yeah, have a bite.
I've heard they're good
in situations like this
yeah hah now I'm ready.
(screaming angrily)
(bright upbeat music)
I give up.
(audience cheering)
[Narrator] (mumbles) Conan
and Andy's Epic Saber Battle
brought to you by Snickers